sometimes it's worth visiting I'm gonna
do something that I've never done before
which is that I'm going to revisit and
kind of reassess my look at hell-bent
which was the final Doctor Who episode
of series 9 because I feel like at this
point I do actually understand what the
episode was going for him what it was
supposed to be one of the side effects
of the fact that I do these reviews
immediately after seeing the episode and
I don't look at anyone elses reactions
before giving them is that I may be
misinterpreting stuff or in the case of
Hell bet I may just simply not get it
but I actually really want to thank you
guys for all the stuff that went on the
comments section it was by far the most
active comments that has ever happened
for any video I've done and while this
isn't gonna be really a comment response
video I do want to shout out to you guys
because what was put down in the
comments is a big part of what has
gotten me to go back watch it again and
now do this new video I do particularly
want to single out Dark Angel scruffy
who put a really wonderful
well-thought-out explanation for what it
was the episode was going for and I get
it now I'm not sure I can explain it
quite as well as he did you can go back
to the comments section on my last video
to get his exact words but basically he
explained why it is justified that Clara
get this extra extra extra send-off and
why it is actually really important that
the doctor go to the lengths that he
does to save her because as it is
pointed out by me or a shoulder or
whatever I'll just call her me Clara is
not just the companion at this point she
is so entangled in his timeline thanks
to the events of things like name of the
doctor and listen that they are now
effectively two halves of the same
person she has been there for every
regeneration helping all at various
points along the way well before she was
just actually travelling with him so
that actually justifies him going to
more extreme lengths to save her than he
has anybody else ever because he's not
just saving his companion his friend
he's trying to preserve one half of
himself and that also lends a certain
point see to what happens with her at
the end with him being unable to
remember her because she basically has
to save him and
universe from himself because she sees
the lengths that he goes to just a saber
him like this this is not good so with
him not being able to remember her and I
do I do still like the way that that's
played where he remember gotten
something and even knows what it is but
just the details they're gone to him so
you know what I get it now and that's
something that I could not say when I
did my previous review so does that
change my feelings about the overall
episode not really I now think better of
it than I did the first time I saw it
certainly but I still can't say that I
liked it I don't do numerical ratings on
these episodes but if I did say a rating
out of 10 this reassessment would only
bump it up 1 2 points at the most and I
think the thing that keeps me from being
on board with this is just fundamental
problems with what it is doing now that
I understand what it's doing I think I
can articulate that better I saw pretty
clearly in the comments and well wasn't
a hundred percent but for the most part
people who liked this episode or loved
it were fans of Clara people who had
more issues with it tended to not be
such big fans of Clara and that I think
really speaks to the heart of why I
couldn't quite get on board with this
I've never hated Clara I've never really
loved her either but what I don't like
about this episode is that it makes her
clearly definitively and kind of
irrevocably the most important person in
the doctor's life ever and I don't like
that I don't like the show basically
telling me how to rank the importance of
people in his life one of my favorite
things about Doctor Who is that
everybody is entitled to their own
favorites you can have your favorite
companion your own favorite doctor your
favorite villains and it doesn't have to
do the same as anybody else's in your
opinion is just as valid as anybody
else's and while this episode does not
necessarily say she is the best
companion ever it does really say she's
the most important companion ever no one
else will ever be as important to him as
she is and I don't like being told that
by this episode now I have to kind of
pick apart as to why it's this episode
that broke my back on that one because
most of the reasons that she is really
important actually happened in other
episodes they
having back in name of the doctor which
I liked a lot they haven't in listen
which I almost like the bar but there's
just something about you know you you'd
have to make an argument you'd have to
extrapolate you'd have to put together a
case based on those things as to why she
was the most important person in his
life
however this episode hell-bent we are
told flat out by me that kind of runs
counter to a great deal of what I like
about Doctor Who like for instance I
think it was essential that in doomsday
that when the doctor was talking to Rose
and when he faded out he did not finish
that sentence and we did not actually
hear him say the words I love you I
think it's hard to make an argument that
he was gonna say anything other than
that but if you don't like that idea you
the show is not forcing you to accept it
another example in the end of time
Russell T Davies and some of the other
producers have said very clearly that
the woman who shows up at various ports
is intended to be the doctor's mother
but they don't say that flat-out so
you're not forced to accept that you are
allowed some wiggle room to come up with
your own preferred headcanon in my case
I actually like to think it's Romana can
I make an argument for that well no but
I am allowed the freedom to believe that
if I choose to so what I don't like
about this episode is it takes away your
ability to make your own choice as to
who's the most important for him and
like I've said the the pieces and the
evidence were there already but having
the show flat-out tell me it just rubs
me the wrong way if you already like
this companion or in some cases young
people love her and that's fine so if
you already like her that much being
told she's the most important man cool
awesome but if you're not that I'm born
with her yeah it's a problem so while I
still personally don't really like this
episode I now do understand what it was
going for and for what it was actually
trying to accomplish it did its job
pretty well so I certainly won't say
that it's a bad episode only that what
it was doing is something that I don't
want done I don't want things laid out
that cleanly I know certain ambiguities
and ways
moffat we'll leave things hanging and
not answer questions Russell T Davies
did it to the two examples I cited with
him but regardless I know people
complained about that I loved that I
loved wiggle room I love giving enough
that fans and viewers can come up with
their answers but they are given enough
freedom that that answer does not have
to be exactly what the people who made
the show intended and I feel like we've
had that choice taken away from us with
this episode
I suppose that's it have you ever had an
episode of Doctor Who just completely
get a reassessment on the rewatch you
either like the first time that you read
watch and go oh no there's all sorts of
problems or you didn't like any watching
one you know what it's not too bad
whatever it was for you drop something
down in the comments and let's talk
about it until next time this council is
adjourned